At this point, since their were only
three remaining problematic enrollments,
I printed out all of them.
However, this time when
I looked at the records,
I wasn't really sure
what the problem was.
I ended up asking a Udacity
data scientist if he knew what
was going wrong.
He pointed out that these students
were all Udacity test accounts.
Which he could tell because they
had is Udaucity equal to true.
These test accounts aren't guaranteed
to be present in the daily
engagement table.
This is really good to know.
I should also probably be excluding any
test accounts from my analysis anyway.
At this point, there weren't any
more surprising data points.
I did go ahead and move all of
the Udacity test accounts from the data
right away since I didn't plan to
include them in any future analysis.
First, I created a set of all the
Udacity test accounts by looping over
the enrollment data, and I found that
there were six of them in this data set.
Then I wrote a function to remove any
data associated with those accounts.
Finally, I called my function
on all three of my tables and
checked how many records
were left in each.
Most of the data is still included,
which is what I expected.
I did create new variables for
the updated data, just in case I ever
want to look at the original data again.